my biggest laugh was when Danny first
lifts up the the tent and the amount of
smoke that comes out from under it it's
not that poisonous go really fast all
right
[Applause]
mine was
so quick which was just Charlie handing
Dennis papers he doesn't know oh yeah
you should probably start at the top of
the story I know what the story is all
right it was game five of the World
Series I I clearly laughed towards the
very end yeah and the second time the
second round of that yeah right at the
very end your reaction gets me and I
have to look down because I'm laughing
stop handing me babe he didn't tell me
you were gonna do that oh you just
started doing it yeah yeah so it was
actually mildly irritating to me like I
knew it was funny but like but I'm
trying to remember my lines I'm trying
to do my lines which I probably picked
up on and then you did it more yeah
[Music]